have you ever been chatting with a  friend on Facebook and suddenly gotten  the urge to play some games with them  I'm Tony and this is your instant game  spot news update Facebook has announced  its new instant games platform if you're  using the messenger app on iOS or  Android you can tap the new controller  icon and load up one of the games  instantly and even challenge your  friends to be your high-score the  selection ranges from arcade classics  like Galaga and Space Invaders to more  modern games like endless Lake in Words  With Friends frenzy seems like a pretty  good way to spice up a conversation if  you don't actually have anything to say  Facebook's instant games platform is  currently available in 30 countries and  it's part of the company's push to  engage with users  we'll have to see what's next for the  social media giant but for all the  latest games on Facebook mobile devices  and consoles you're already in the right  place